so i want to jump in right away with
this uh because it is simply fantastic
really it's one of my favorite videos
of all time this kind of brilliant
comedy
is what you might have gotten from a
comedy show like snl back when comedy
was still legal now we have to settle
for getting our comedy from real life
so um so here is western australian
premier mark mcgowan he has uh recorded
a video where he's trying to communicate
some basic things about about covid to
the aboriginal community in the area
and so he's decided to to begin with
speak very very slowly
using using small words so that they can
understand him
but he's even hired an aboriginal elder
to translate for him in real time
and the results are
truly extraordinary let's watch
important message to keep aboriginal
people safe
and this message
is proper important one to keep
everybody
safe one
you can die from the corona or get
really sick
you will again
pass away
from this groaner
or you better get really sick one
it's time to get the corona needle to
keep people and country strong
djinn
he timed to give him this needle
longer corona
to keep him but all the people
and country probably strong
one the corona needle will protect kids
old people men and women
well
do you uncrown a needle
gonna keep
mail a safe one for all our kids
and for all the men and women
okay many people around the world um
sorry uh i didn't understand any of that
i need it translated into american
english
we need a third translator there
actually i i did it understand it in
fact i um i guess the big news here is i
learned just now that i speak aboriginal
australian so i am bilingual that's uh
that's good news
why not just have her if you're gonna do
this
um which you shouldn't in the first
place but why not just have her alone
giving this address
if you really feel that it's necessary
like why do you need to be in the video
too
you can tell that she's actually having
trouble
saying it differently
so that's that's where she's struggling
as a translator
usually i guess the challenge is to you
know translate it correctly but um in
this case she's like looking at the
words and she's trying to think how am i
supposed to say it differently from what
you already just said
so she just puts the word one after
everything she says
um but so if you're gonna do it just
have her alone
better yet
don't do it at all
because this is
this is truly racist by definition and
and i i hate to uh to engage in the
whole
the left or the real racist thing
but but actually they are
right i mean it's true
it's true because the definition of
racism
is um and it does have an actual
definition
it's got nothing to do with what we hear
the critical race theory proponents it's
power plus privilege and all that's got
nothing to do with any of that
racism is actually a very simple thing
racism is
the belief
that a certain race of people are
inferior to you
because of their race
so it's not even a belief that an
individual person of another race is
inferior to you
that can be a rude thing to think or say
um
but it's the belief that an entire race
because of the race are inferior to
yourself
that's racism
like anything else there are a lot of
other
things that you can think and things you
could say that are rude and not nice
but aren't racist that's what racism is
and so we see how in in fact really the
left actually are the real races because
this is how they feel
this guy what's this guy's name again
mark mcgowan
he he looks at the aboriginal people as
clearly like children
and so rather than speaking to them like
adults and saying what he would say to
everybody else
is to slow down
i mean they speak english that's the
point here but he's got to slow down use
very small words
and then have someone next to him
translating it
into sort of a colloquial vernacular
that is you you believe that they're
inferior to you
and this is what we always get from the
left
um
from these white knight white leftists
they think that um that other races they
they take this paternalistic pose
and they treat other races as though
they're all a bunch of children
whereas the the non-racist
point of view
is to say is to just hold everyone to
the same standard
have the same expectations for everybody
i don't care what race you are i mean if
we all speak english you should be able
to understand english
even if it's not in the in in your we
all have our own colloquial kind of way
of speaking but you should be able to
understand english that isn't that isn't
uh couched in your own colloquial
language
or vernacular
that's the expectation i have for
everybody
that's why i'm against affirmative
action say hold up have the same
expectation for everybody hold everyone
to the same standard i don't care what
race you are
here's the standard here's what we're
looking for based on the merits
and whatever race you are there's no
reason why you can't
um
live up to that there's no reason why
you can't get over that bar and if you
can't then you don't deserve to get
hired for the position or to go to that
school or whatever it is
so this is if you're a white leftist i
mean it's really a
members of the other race uh you do take
a paternalistic view they're inferior to
you
and then members of your own race you
hate them also
so it's just it's just racism and hatred
and
resentment
sprayed in all directions towards
everybody
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content